la pp la fédération des parents d'élèves
de l'enseignement public souhaite que
les mères ouvre toutes les écoles invité
sur france info le porte-parole de la pp
hubert sa lune a précisé qu'il
souhaitait une rentrée progressive avec
des règles sanitaires strictes exemple
en dédoublant les classes c'est à dire
pour qu'il y ait moins d'élèves présents
en même temps et pour les écoles qu'ils
ne peuvent pas appliquer de protocole
sanitaire selon albert salle une je cite
il va falloir un plan d'investissement
pour la rentrée au mois de septembre
et pour en parler nous retrouvons gérard
paumier président de la peep la
fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public
un jour gérard paumier merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors à ce jour
neuf mille établissements restent encore
fermés 10 % des communes
d'après vous est-ce qu'il faut que tout
soit rouvert écoutez nous nous avons
toujours eu la position suivante qui est
très très clair c'est que partout où le
protocole sanitaire peut être respectée
et bien les différents acteurs devraient
pouvoir se mettre d'accord pour la
réouverture de des glaces oui notre
objectif c'était que quasiment tout voir
sans bon sens d'aider des écoles
puissent être ouverte afin d'accueillir
des enfants
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
d'une fermeture qui serait prolongé dans
ces écoles est ce que par exemple vous
redoutez une augmentation du décrochage
scolaire alors les décrochages
hélas en fait il est déjà avéré de même
que l'éloignement donc il y avait bien
entendu avant le confinement des ja du
décrochage
il s'est renforcé de manière terrible
avec le confinement est bien entendu le
fait de pour des enfants de d'être
resté au bout du compte que plusieurs
mois sans avoir vu
l'enseignant ou d'enseignante sans avoir
vu les camarades et bientôt cela a des
incidences nous avons observé par
exemple des des problèmes psychologiques
qui se sont renforcées qui se sont
révélés avec le confinement et ben il ya
aussi la question disons de
l'intégration sociale l'école ça a du
sens on parlait de problèmes
psychologiques est ce que vous voulez
dire par là exactement
nous avons constaté
premièrement alors c'est vrai pour les
adolescents mais c'est vrai aussi pour
les plus petits le fait d'être confiné à
gênés avec confiné à générer des des
problèmes de comportement entre les
mains un ras-le-bol quelquefois d'une
promiscuité chance et au sein de la
famille
donc ça c'est un exemple d'un problème
que nous avons relevé et que les
psychiatres les pédiatres relèvent
il ne s'agit pas de simples impressions
de notre part et cela alors qu'on dit
souvent que les enfants s'adaptent
beaucoup mieux que nous à ce genre de
situation alors nous sommes le 3 juin
est ce qu'il est possible selon vous que
tous les élèves retrouvent le chemin de
l'école ou en uvre une fois avant la fin
de l'année scolaire comme le souhaite le
ministre de l'éducation nationale alors
je précise que les enfants se sont très
bien adaptés mais il y as hatten une
limite à tout alors oui nous nous
souhaitons que le maximum d'enfants
puissent se reprendre le chemin de
l'école
ne serait-ce que que partiellement on a
vu que les dispositifs sont nombreux
quelquefois cesser ce sont des ddd
classe très très réduite
il y à des rotations au niveau de
l'occupation des établissements au
niveau des classes et là encore je
voudrais
signalez ouvre à trie que trop de classe
au sein des écoles restent fermées et
inoccupé donc je dirais que bien entendu
la question n'est pas facile mais je
crois qu'avec de la volonté
et puis surtout une envie d'agir de tous
les acteurs je crois qu'on pourrait
mieux faire
est-ce que selon vous il faudra adopter
des mesures supplémentaires pour la
rentrée du mois de septembre a très
certainement est d'ailleurs concernant
dix ans de le plan d'investissement que
vous évoquiez et cesser dès maintenant
puisque au départ nous nous partons déjà
avec un handicap qui est que beaucoup
beaucoup trop d'écoles était sous-équipé
est par exemple les sanitaires les
lavabos les salles disons de vie était
déjà dans un état déplorable
et vous imaginez donc ne pas le gap
qu'il faut combler afin donc de ce
praticien les exigences qui sont encore
plus importantes du fait de la crise
sanitaire et donc cesser dès maintenant
dès maintenant qu'il faut agir pour
pouvoir investir à bon escient
il ya beaucoup d'écoles concernés par ce
besoin peut-être dans un plan de
financement parce que les mesures de
restrictions sanitaires ne sont pas
possibles à mettre en place pour nommant
l'observatoire de la sécurité dans les
établissements scolaires avait noté que
30 à 40% des établissements nécessité
des travaux importants
merci beaucoup gérard paumier pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de la peep la
fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public